experience what does that mean
you guys [ __ ] mr. final I could be an
honorary Australian I love ski talk
about his weight losshow is big yeah
guys come on wow you look like a homo I
could beat you could be in a really good
movie about a crazy person from
Australia right down under it's a porno
what are you doing I'm gonna pull the
knife out now that's a knife let's go
with your boots you were on purpose what
is going on with us
those boots
Brian bro you would do store and you
like perfect you like perfect I'll take
lose one somewhere who do you know you
[ __ ] these are [ __ ] these are these
are building patterns gonna put your
knife down so I please please
threatening people okay keep your knife
right and we fought for real
get out of here Brian I love you you
know you don't have your headphones on
you [ __ ] that's why everything's going
on my fault big part of it get out of
here you son of a [ __ ] but love you
stay safe wash your hands
that's a mushroom hat that's a minute am
I sure come back here for a second you
kids can hold for month but another hat
it's a better hat for you damn it's
mushroom drink buttermilk at the dollar
[ __ ] you guys man had it with your aegis
[ __ ]
[Applause]